brent thomas congratulations you've made
it into the third
and final round of this competition now
we're sending you back to your home
forges
to recreate this iconic weapon from
history
the tizona del cid oh my
what is that looking at the blade
i see this super ornate guard and pummel
and i'm thinking how can i get all this
detail into it
and make it strong and functional
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days good luck brother good luck
today i have to make l-sids to zona
i'm getting the tang drawn out but i
noticed the tang
is getting twisted and i'm really
worried at this point because this could
cause
a lot of stress i will definitely have a
little catching up to do tomorrow
we're here in west virginia let's get
these burners burning
l-sids blade is a very light blade i'm
really concerned about how i'm going to
keep it at that weight
after a few hours of forging i finally
have my piece set to length
climb up on my little stepping stool and
uh i can barely get the tip of this
blade
into the quench quench went all right
tomorrow i move on to the pretty stuff
it's day two and i am gonna start over
it's pedal to the metal i gotta hurry i
absolutely need to quench this plate
tonight or i am gonna be drastically
behind
so i've got my blade forged out to the
shape i want
i'm leaving my tang thicker than i need
so that as i'm holding this
gigantic long piece it doesn't bend at
the tang
[Music]
today i got my blade forged and quenched
so happy
today's main goal is to get the guard
assembly a lot of artistic work involved
with this piece
this is the kind of work i'm really used
to these little small twists and bins
basic blacksmithing so i've got all my
welding done now it's time to clean this
thing up on the grinder
that is beautiful i love that
right now i've got the majority of my
guard constructed i have to add a little
crossbar
to weld on as a cross guard for the
pommel i plan on just cutting a little
cone out
i got it nice and sharp my fit and
finish isn't perfect
but i made this sword in three days so
even if you feel like you can't do it
just give it a shot you really never
know what's gonna happen
here we are the last day of this build
uh everything's progressed nicely so far
now i'm going to start the mustard
patina process
basically the vinegar and the mustard
reacts to high carbon steel the blade
begins to slightly rust
and wipe it off and you have a nice
little outline of where your mustard was
all right
i am very very very happy with that that
is
wild before i see this blade off i've
just got to test it one time
and the blade just passes right through
like hot butter
eats your heart out else said i got it
done
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
keel test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
weapon deliver some slashes thrust on
this bore carcass
brent here purse you ready for this yeah
let's do it so my knees will stop
shaking
all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
wow
good job what
all right bread let's talk about your
tizona here the balance of this blade
allows me to really move around with it
and it's a very sharp edge overall this
weapon is one you can move and bring to
combat
and it will kill thank you sir good job
all right thomas your turn you ready
ready as i'll ever be all right let's do
this
huh
[Music]
your tip thrust easy and cuts on the way
out
and your edge as you can see same number
of cuts cut all the way through
your first sword it will kill good job
thank you it's okay to be thrilled kid
[Laughter]
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the armored chop
to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i'll be
chopping into our
armored knights here brent you're up
first you ready yes sir
all right brett you've got a couple of
chips and rolls
i don't know that it'll affect the
performance of your blade
it's still sharp as far as the design of
your blade
that's a very slick handle i like to
not be able to do that as easily but you
did good
strong sword one piece good job thank
you
tomas are you ready i'm ready swing away
all right thomas this has a really fine
edge to it
and where it made contact there are
multiple rolls
it's that super fine edge just being
pushed over as it hits that armor
it's an amazingly light sword for as
wide as that is that that's very good
work i mean it's a
very broad blade and it's got a very
light feel to it
the handle on this the wrapping on there
gives a good grip
it felt really good in my hand bottom
line
it's a strong sword held up beautifully
good job
thank you
all right bladesmith this is the
sharpness test the fish slice
test the edge of your weapon that will
slash away at these salmons
frontier first you ready let's do it do
[Music]
this
[Music]
wow good job
all right let's talk about your sword
here cut all the way through the fish
except for that
it's a sharp edge all the cuts here are
very clean overall sir
it'll cut awesome thank you all right
thomas
ready for sushi i am ready let's do this
it's really down to the wire at this
point if my blade doesn't perform
as well as brent's i'm definitely out of
this competition
wow good job thank you
all right thomas every cut was clean all
the way
through once again the edge here despite
some of the roles it took earlier
have no issues in performance and
quality of cuts
overall sir it will cut all right blade
smiths
the new fortune fire champion is
brent congratulations you're the new
forage and fire champion
thomas unfortunately a setback in your
home forge
cost you a little bit of detail when it
came to your final product
and for that reason please leave the
forge
i'm super disappointed that i didn't win
but i came out here
i made a knife with a drum set i made a
sword for the first time
i'm just so proud of myself for having
taken the risk
putting myself outside of my comfort
zone and
right now i feel like a rock star
brent congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's the title
that comes with the check
for ten thousand dollars good job my
friend
oh it feels amazing the adrenaline right
now is just through the friggin roof
i'd like to thank god for this
opportunity my wife for her support
just thank you everyone having trouble
containing everything
there's so many emotions inside right
now that i just want to let them all out
[Applause]
you